while you're away
your dad
came by the house
what
what are you talking about
my dad was here
today yeah and he talked to my dad for
like a while and then he just left what
do you want what do you say I don't know
but my dad doesn't even know that I know
in fact he lied about why we had to
postpone the racetrack he said it was a
business emerge so how do you know it's
my pops
foreign
I'm gonna close the door on this whole
situation so just
I know
that Wish isn't gonna come true
your Dad's here and mine isn't giving
straight answers and and
this folder has all the answers you need
foreign
[Music]
pops
don't bother trying to cover up I know
it was here
so
you all really weren't gonna tell me
oh well we were just discussing yeah
what the next steps should be and now
that you know
I mean
do you want to meet with your father
well that depends
what does he want with me
what
you do why can't I just answer a simple
ass question it's complicated
okay listen
to be blunt and your father's saying all
the right things but
lose my trustworthy
now let's see he's a con man who was
convicted of robbing an old man he said
oh to money
and you were his lawyer
right
yeah I read the report a report
I asked Jeffrey to look into my father
and Uncle Phil wasn't too happy about it
where you want is that why Jeffrey loved
decision to part ways was Mutual not on
my part
listen we will pick this up later okay
what else did you learn from this
Jeffrey report pops had it rough in the
jump
is that he was a gangster who got killed
in jail his mom died when he was 15 he
dropped out of school at 19 he got
arrested for stealing a car so he
already had a prior when he was facing
the assault charges
he didn't have a second chance like I
did
it's a sympathetic view of your father
will
he doesn't deserve sympathy
is that what you're saying
you know reading that report
I realized that had been wrong about him
my whole life
because everyone told me he walked out
on me
like he had a choice
but the truth is he got arrested
and my mom just cut him off
you see
that's where it gets complicated well
your father is volatile and
unpredictable and we didn't want you in
contact with someone who would
manipulate you or disrupt your life
I'm sorry will
that's why we were determined to keep
you from reaching out to him
and
that's why I didn't want you to
track down somebody who could have
reached out to you all these years when
he was in prison but didn't
and I didn't want him to hurt you
anymore than he already had
and
[Music]
he showed up here today
yeah
the decision to see him or not is still
yours to make
what do you want to do